kelly was just on our our set the other
day and she raved about how just being
able to spend time with you and there's
that beautiful picture of noah you
really have become a grandmother to
those kids absolutely they're my
grandkids too yeah
what is the special bond between you and
her between me you and callie oh my god
kelly is my daughter she's been
living with uh i mean you know she's
been living with me since she was like
11 so she's actually a sister to my
girls and a daughter to me i mean i
don't see any difference
i hear you on that um also this western
is really
a great your family had its hands in
this
what do you think of this western and
now telling the story of all these black
folks they use the names of real cowboys
one in three cowboys were black how
important is it to tell these stories
the way they're being told now
well you know black cowboys have kind of
been left out of the history and it's so
important to tell this story because
there were
many black cowboys and they played a big
role in history and just acknowledged
them is amazing i mean
i cannot wait to see this movie i know
with the cast that's in it that they're
going to kill it and uh it's just an
important story to be told
how were you never in were you you were
never in a western why why weren't you
in westerns i was in a western i was in
one called buffalo bill
the buffalo soldiers
buffalo
buffalo soldiers so i did i did at least
one but you know the interesting thing
about history
is that it's his story
so this is
our story
because we're telling it
and that's true as is the more stuff
that we do
with us being the storytellers
then you'll see history from a different
perspective or life from a different
perspective and so it's important it
always cracked me up that all the great
comedies
of the 70s and 80s the black comedies
that's my mama blah blah blah they were
all written by white men and so
therefore
those stories appeal to white people
looking at black people where black
people saw those stories and said
that's not the way we wouldn't do it
like that yeah starting with starting
starting with horror films how many
horror films you look and say who the
hell is going to go in the house like
that no black folks no black folk
by the way family night out date night
out
oh it's all of that
yeah we've both been familiar
it's a family night and i'm just so
excited i'm so proud of my son-in-law
i cannot wait to see this movie i heard
he had his hand and everything like they
were taught he had his absolutely he
worked so hard on this this was a
passion project for all of them and it
shows
[Music]